All right, for our audience and people
who are familiar with you, tell them
about you, your experience, and why
you're running for Congress. Sure. My
name is James Settelmeyer. I'm running
for congressional district number two. I
look at this very much that I'm asking
the citizens of congressional district
two for a job. So, to me, this is a job
interview.
And with any job interview, you should
look at the qualifications of the
individuals and what they bring to the
table for you as the employer. So, as I
look at it,
I have a unique experience. I have grown
up in agriculture, fourth generation
Nevadan in that respect. I went to
California Polytechnic State University,
came back, served on a local
conservation district for 28 years.
I did 6 years for Governor Guinn on the
Nevada State Conservation Commission.
Uh through that time frame, I gained a
lot of experience in the field of
agriculture and many other issues.
Uh in that respect, I also did 6 years
for the Small Business Administration as
an ombudsman, making sure to look out
for small businesses in Washington
environment and the federal environment.
If you look at it, usually larger
businesses know how to navigate.
Small businesses, not so much. So, we
try to look after those interests.
During that time frame, I got more
involved with the Nevada State
Conservation Commission, which got me
involved in the Nevada Legislature. My
predecessor was Lynn Hettrick. Uh during
that time frame, we decided that I
should run.
Uh decided to do that uh nowhere kind of
and in that respect, I did 4 years in
the Nevada Legislature. I then followed
that up with 8 years in the Nevada
Senate, where I was actually the
minority leader, the Republican leader
of the state legislature for the Senate.
During that time frame, there were some
issues that came up.
Unfortunately, I had a governor and uh
some Democrat Party members who decided
that they wanted to violate the Nevada
Constitution and increase taxes without
the requisite vote.
So, I took the charge. I actually kind
of had to put up the ranch as collateral
in order to get that done.
Uh luckily, some businesses came
afterwards and decided to help me fund
and the courts refunded it after they
determined at the United Nevada Supreme
Court
that the governor and the Democratic
Party violated the Nevada Constitution,
unanimously. You don't get very many
unanimous decisions out of the Nevada
Supreme Court, which then caused them to
have to refund over a hundred million
dollars to the citizens and the
businesses of the state of Nevada.
Uh from there, I was kind of happy to be
out of politics.
Other than talking to Governor Lombardo,
he asked me to be the director of the
Department of Conservation Natural
Resources.
I was honored. I stepped forth and I did
that
uh for three and a half years,
basically. Uh in that respect though,
when Congressman Amodei made a rather
sudden announcement that he was no
longer going to continue,
uh a lot of discussions had to be had
with my family. Had a lot of friends
that wanted me to run.
I always thought about running, but it
was more like a five-year plan, not a
five second ago plan. So, in that
respect, I decided to run for
Congressional District 2. I bring
legislative experience, knowledge of the
natural resources, and as a businessman,
I understand that we have to worry about
getting our economy back on track.
Uh in what ways would you vote similar
to how Representative Amodei has voted
and in what ways maybe would you vote
differently than him if you were
elected? You know, I actually followed
Congressman Amodei when he left to go to
Congress, I went into the state Senate.
And you can look at that. I obviously
had very similar viewpoints as
Congressman Amodei representing the same
area. However, there were times that we
were different. I am very focused on
small businesses. Uh not that
Congressman Amodei was not. I am very
well versed in the natural resources
such as water law, which you know,
nobody argues about water in state of
Nevada at all, but that knowledge and
perspective gives me something a little
bit different when it comes to
testifying in a natural resource
committee and things of that nature. Uh
however, you know, he was stronger
probably when it came to legal matters.
I went to law school, however, I'm not a
practicing attorney.
And in that respect, he has that legal
expertise.
Mhm.
Do you support the Washoe County lands
bill? Couple different versions of them,
but uh to free up tens of thousands of
acres of federal land to be auctioned
for housing and development. You know,
when I look at the concept of the lands
bills that have gone through, I very
much am more leaning towards the concept
that there are obviously areas that are
right next to currently existing growth
because we don't want to leapfrog out.
And having those areas be available
for development, I think is important.
But I also think that we need to look at
a different aspect of it because like if
you look at the Southern Nevada Land
Management Act, when they sell that land
down there, it usually goes for about
350 to 400,000 dollars an acre.
We need affordable attainable housing.
And if you have to buy the land at that
price,
you're not going to have affordable
attainable housing.
So, I think we need to look at the
concept just as the Southern Nevada Land
Management Act, where you actually allow
those funds to not necessarily be paid
or go to maybe conservation easements
for individuals and having the ability
to transfer development rights. So, that
way we can actually keep
or allow the prices of those homes to be
more reasonable
because that's what we're really in a
shortage of in my opinion in this area.
Uh Nevadans continue to tell us that
pocketbook issues are the most important
to them, price of housing, gas,
groceries. Uh what policies would you
support to try and lower costs for
Nevadans? Appreciate that. You know, I
look at some of the things uh the
president has brought forth. You know,
at first he was talking about the beef
people, you know, potentially getting
too much money. I think it's a question
we need to look at the packers.
Uh there's an issue there where you have
four people that literally control 85%
of the industry. That's not supposed to
be allowed. That's called a monopoly.
Uh and then worse is you have two guys
that basically control 46% of that. That
could help lower some of the prices on
meat, not only beef, but poultry as
well.
Uh one of the other things I look at, I
think that we are way too reliant. I
agree with the governor. We are way too
reliant on California gas.
And when that was originally done, that
was done through the Defense Department.
So, they put in pipelines for fuel that
went to Fallon Naval Air Station
and of course went to Nellis Air Force
Base.
Now, in that respect, those lines were
built larger than capacity
so that the communities could benefit
from being able to have fuel delivered
in that mechanism.
Cuz the cheapest way you're ever going
to get fuel delivered is that pipeline.
We need to look and the nation needs to
look if we want to make sure that Fallon
and Nellis and the military has fuel.
We need to look at the idea of
connecting the system throughout the
United States.
Uh specifically here in northern Nevada
pipeline to Utah makes some sense.
A lot of sense, especially if you put it
next to the existing natural gas line.
You really don't have as much
disturbance because again, that area is
already disturbed. Of course, you're
going to have to separate it by 20 to 40
ft. I'm not sure of the exact
requirement. Can't do it right next to
each other.
Uh but those are the things we need to
look at to help people because the cost
of fuel governs so many things.
If you look at everything has to be
delivered by semi trucks which are doing
a fantastic job delivering those things.
But it's costly. And as the price of
fuel goes up, they have to unfortunately
increase their cost.
Uh what's your path to victory in this
district? You know, it's up to the
citizens.
This is up to the citizens of District 2
who they want to represent them. You
know, do they want to have an individual
who has the experience who has been here
for generations
and who's very worried about continuing
this area for generations, continuing it
being the place that we all decided to
move to?
And we got to make sure it doesn't turn
into some place that we don't want it to
be.
And we need to honor that heritage and
also what was given to us by our
forefathers and respect the natural
resources. And that's who I am.
I think that's going to shine.
I have the ability uh having represented
many of the areas for 16 years.
You know, I know how to run a campaign
and I've never lost.
I am going to win.
But, that is only if the citizens
decide to vote for me.